You know,
people often say to their kids,
it doesn't matter whether you win or
lose,
it's how you play the game.
And the kid who of course has no idea
what that means.
It's like,
what do you mean?
Now I'm trying to win.
And the parents says,
no,
it matters how you play.
And the kid pushes them in.
The parents really can't come up with a
good explanation of why that's the case.
They might say,
well,
other kids won't play with you if your.
Oh,
there you go.
Because you could say this is something
to think about.
So there's a game and there's a victory
within the game,
but then there's the set of all games
and there's victory across the set of
old games.
And the victory that you attained across
the set of all games isn't winning all
the games.
It's being invited to play all the
games.
And so if you play fair,
then you're playing a metagame and the
metagame is how to win across the set of
all games.
And so if you teach your child how to
behave properly,
then they always get invited to play.
And that makes them winners and that's
that.
And so if you understand that you
understand something phenomenally
important about the emergence of
morality,
you know,
because people moral relativists in
particular think that morality is
relative,
you know,
and,
and of course human beings are diverse,
just like languages are diverse and
there's more than one playable game,
but there's not really more than one
playable Medicaid.
It's like you're either the kind of
person that other people want to play
with or you're not.
And if you're not the kind of person
that other people want to play with,
then you're a loser.
It's as simple as that.
And that's true of all cultures.
They might be playing different
individual games within their culture.
Undoubtedly they are,
but the set of all games that they play
is still common across cultures.
That's part of what makes us human.
And then you could say as well,
we're actually evolved to detect people
who are good at playing the set of all
possible games.
And we actually know that that's not
theoretical.
We know,
for example,
some things are easy to remember and
some things are hard to remember.
You know,
here's something that's easy to
remember.
You play with someone in need,
cheat man,
you will remember that.
That's like in your mind,
that's not going anywhere,
and so you're great at detecting
cheaters and you remember,
and that's because you can't trust a
cheater and you shouldn't invite a
cheater to play a game with you because
they might cheat.
And so that's part of the innate
morality system.
You remember cheaters because they
aren't good at playing the metagame.
And of course your evolved.
Of course you're adapted to the metagame
because you're the product of this
immense evolutionary history,
right?
And whoever your ancestors were,
which is an unbroken string of
successful reproducers going back three
and a half billion years,
you think about that.
Every single one of your ancestors
successfully reproduced it's
mindboggling.
The chances against that are so.
It's billions,
billions to one.
And here you are,
the line of three and a half billion
years of success.
The whole world was trying to kill you
that whole time.
And here you are.
It's like a.
But you know,
you're still only going to last about 80
years.
So.
But that's,
you know,
still,
good for you.
So anyways,
there were lots of games that your
ancestors were playing across that
immense span of time.
Many,
many,
you know,
Lizard Games and tree dweller games and,
and,
and what,
and Crustacean Games,
you know,
that huge set of games and you're
adapted to win across those games.
All of them.
And that's built into you man.
That's,
that's your central human nature.
That's what makes you social.
And it's not some mere cultural
construct.
Quite the contrary.
It's,
it's so deeply embedded in you.
It's what you are.
Alright?
So,
well this is a story.
It's a game too.
That's another way of thinking about it.
You know,
like that's a monopoly game.
Well,
what's the frame?
Well that's the rules of the game.
And are they,
why do you accept them or it's kind of
arbitrary,
right?
It's like that happens to be the rules.
Hockey has different rules,
basketball has different rules,
but what they share is that they have
rules.
Okay?
So there's a frame,
that's the rules.
And then within the frame there's a goal
and the goal is whatever the rules
dictate,
you know,
there's usually,
it's usually the construction of a
hierarchy of success within a frame.
And so that's what you play.
So you play monopoly.
It's like,
well we'll accept the rules,
that's the social contract.
And then we'll each try to win.
And that'll be fun.
We find that amusing music.
And if you lose,
what do you say while you say,
well,
there's always another game.
And so that's great.
So if you have that attitude and you
play fair,
then it doesn't matter that much that
you,
whether you win or lose,
although you still want to try to win
because otherwise you're not a good
player,
but you accept defeat gracefully because
you can play again and so and you'll win
some and you lose some.
And so that's not so bad,
you know?
And even if you lose,
well maybe you learn something and,
and you're doing a lot more than one
thing while you're playing monopoly,
you know,
you're having a conversation and
learning how to interact with people and
learning how to regulate your emotions.
And so even if you lose,
if you have any sense,
you win.
And if your kids have any sense,
they know that.
And so that way you buffer them against
defeat.
It's like,
yeah,
I get on next time.
It's like,
so okay,
then you should try.
But it's okay.
And,
and that's,
that's,
that's useful information for people to
know.
So.
Alright,
so you're always in one of these little
frameworks and there's just no getting
out of it.
So.
And that's because,
you know,
at any given moment this is like,
it's like field theory.
There used to be psychological theories
that talked about the field of human
experience,
something like that.
And this is kind of what that is.
This is a field.
And basically what happens is you parse
out a little part of the world say,
and so you can handle.
So let's say it has some duration.
You're not aiming at something 50 years
in the future.
It's because how the hell are you going
to do that?
There's too many variables,
you know,
so you're aiming at some handleable
amount of time and you pause it,
a goal in there.
And you plot your route and then that
tells you what's up and tells you what's
down.
[inaudible] moves you towards the goal
and down moves you away from the goal
and that sets up your motivational
framework so that you have some worth
attaining.
You know,
that's a really interesting thing to
know too.
It's like,
why have a goal ball?
It's easy,
no goal,
no positive emotion because you
experienced positive emotion by noticing
that you're moving towards a goal and so
if you don't have to have a goal while
you can't have any positive emotion,
so better have a goal,
and so you might say,
well,
what should the goal be?
Well,
we could start by saying,
well,
any goal is better than none,
and then we might say,
well,
it should be a goal that other people
will let you pursue because otherwise
it's going to be kind of difficult and
maybe there'll be even happy to help you
pursue it.
That would even be better.
And maybe it's a goal that would enable
you to learn how to pursue other goals.
Well,
you pursue that goal.
Boy,
that would really be good.
And so you can see that your goal is
parameterized,
but that doesn't mean that any old goal
works.
It means there's some goals that were
nicely and some not so nicely.
There are playable games and non
unplayable games.
That's a good way of thinking about it.
And you want to have a playable game and
there's a lot of them,
lawyer,
plumber,
you know,
actor,
whatever,
they're,
they're playable games and,
and it's not obvious which ones better,
but it's certainly obvious which ones
are sustainable and which ones are
worse.
And so there's a set of playable games
and you need to extract from that set of
playable games,
a game that suits you.
And that would be partly due to your
temperament,
you know,
because extroverted people want to play
an extroverted game and highly neurotic
people want to play a safe game and
agreeable people want to play a generous
game and disagreeable people wanting to
play a game that's highly competitive so
they can win and you know,
fine,
but they're all within the realm of
playable games.
And that means they're socially
acceptable as well.
And so that means it isn't just
arbitrary,
it isn't just relative what you decide
to do,
it's heavily parameterized.
There's only,
there's a set of playable games and it's
large,
the set is large,
but it there are commonalities within
it.
And that's why there are commonalities.
That's why morality has a common basis
fundamentally.
And so that's partly what we're trying
to investigate is like what's up?
What does that mean?
What does it mean?
Is there such a thing?
Now,
one thing to remember is that if you
don't erect a hierarchical structure
with a something to aim at,
you got no positive motivation because
you experience positive motivation in
relationship to a goal,
not from attaining the goal,
that satisfaction and besides it's
fleeting,
you know perfectly well,
you graduate from university,
Poof,
next day you have a problem,
which is what do you do next?
And that's a.
that's a tough problem.
It's not like you've solved your
problems by winning that game.
You just introduced the problem of
having to introduce another game.
So it's unreliable as a source of
positive emotion.
But what's reliable is you set a goal
and you try to attain it,
and then that gives your life that
literally provides your life with
meaning.
That's what meaning is.
Now it's more than that,
but that's what it is.
And so then you might ask yourself,
well,
what's a really good goal?
Well,
that's what we're trying to figure out.
What's a really good goal?
And now,
okay,
so you got that.
So now I'm going to walk through at
least partly through.
We'll see how far we get.
I'm gonna Walk Through Pinocchio with
you because that's what the movie's
about.
And it's uh,
it's hard to say how it came about.
Like it was written the story by a guy
named Claudia I,
C o,
l l O v I,
it's quite a bit different.
The story,
that story,
the written one from the Disney version,
the Disney version was a product of the
collaboration of geniuses,
of animation essentially.
So they were artistic geniuses,
great at capturing motion and emotion
and all of that.
Be Stellar at that.
And imaginative,
tremendously imaginative,
but collectively imaginative.
And so they put together a collective
product.
And you might say,
well,
how did they do that?
Exactly?
It's like,
well,
they were good storytellers.
What does that mean?
Well,
it means you know,
the story that works and the story that
doesn't.
And maybe partly what you do is you kind
of think out a story and you think,
well,
what if this happens?
And maybe this should happen.
Oh,
that's the thing.
that would work.
It's like the little flash of
inspiration,
right?
It's like you got a piece of the puzzle
that fits you think,
yeah,
that would work there.
And then you talk to the other people
and you generate ideas and someone says,
well,
what if,
what if they do this?
And everyone goes now,
now that's just not believable.
No one's going to buy that.
And someone else has a little
revelation.
They said,
well,
you know,
it makes some sense somehow with if they
do this.
And everybody goes,
Oh yeah,
that,
that really,
that really works.
It's like,
why?
Why,
Why?
You don't know.
You don't know why it works,
but it works because it works because
it's the right story.
And so what does that mean?
Well,
it's kind of associated with this
metagame idea.
You know,
it's like there's a story that you
should be acting out that works across
games and you have an inkling of it.
Do you have a notion of it?
You have a vague apprehension of it.
It's sort of built into that archetype.
That's an archetype.
And so then when you read a story that
works,
you're just entranced by it and you all
know that you go to a movie and it's a
great movie and it's like you're just
blown away.
You know,
it's a movie can pull you in and turn
you into one of the screen characters
and I can run you through a huge set of
emotions.
I saw this movie once about South
America.
It started with this guy running out of
a subway naked and he didn't know where
he was and it turned out that he had
been absconded by,
uh,
the totalitarian death squads and he
couldn't remember anything about
himself.
And he went back to his village.
And basically what happened was that he
ended up back in the totalitarian death
grip.
And it was,
it showed how the fascist state had
saturated the village completely,
and so it was a tragedy and you could
see with every action that this guy,
this amnestic guy,
as he recreated him himself and
remembered his identity,
was going to travel down exactly the
same road because nothing had changed.
And by the time I wish I've looked for
what that movie was for years,
I've never been able to find it again.
But when the movie was over,
every single person in the theater was
crying and not just a little bit.
It was like they were just out of it.
It was brilliant,
terrifying movie.